it's my hive privileged sent to you the
President of the United States
vice president mr. speaker members of
the Senate the House of Representatives
of the United States in fulfilling my
beauty report upon the State of the
Union and proud to say to you that the
spirit of the American people would
never higher than it is today
the union was never more closely knit
together and this country was never more
deeply determined to face the solemn
tasks the part the response of the
American people has been instantaneous
and it will be sustained
until our security is a sure
exactly one year ago today I said to
this Congress when the dictators are
ready to make war upon us
they will not wait for an act of war on
our part they not we will choose the
time and the place and the method of
their attack we now know their choice of
the time a peaceful Sunday morning
December 7th 1941
we know that choice of a place an
outpost an American outpost in the
Pacific we know their choice of the
method the method of Hitler himself
Japan's scheme of conquest goes back
half a century it was not merely a
policy of seeking living room it was a
plan which included the subjugation of
all the peoples in the Far East and in
the islands of the Pacific and the
domination of that oath by Japanese
military and naval control on the
western coast of long Central and South
America the development of this
ambitious conspiracy was marked by the
war against China in 1894 the subsequent
occupation of Korea the war against
Russia in nineteen for the illegal
fortification of the mandated Pacific
Islands following 1920 the seizure of
Manchuria in 1931 and the invasion of
China in 1937 a similar policy of
criminal conquest was adopted by Italy
the fascists first revealed therein
real designs in Libya and Tripoli in
1935 they cease Abyssinia their goal was
the domination of our Africa Egypt
parts of France and the entire
Mediterranean world but the dreams of
empire of the Japanese and fascist
leaders was modest in comparison with
the gargantuan aspirations of Hitler and
his Nazis even before they came to power
in 1933 their plans for that conquest
had been grown they provided for
ultimate domination not of any one
section of the world but of the whole
earth and all the oceans dumped when
Hitler organized his Berlin Rome Tokyo
Alliance all these plans of conquest
became a single plan under this in
addition to her own schemes of conquest
Japan role was obviously to cut off our
supply of weapons of war
to Britain and Russia and Trenor
weapons which increasingly was speeding
the day of Hitler's doom the act of
Japan at Pearl Harbor was intended to
stun us to terrify us
to such an extent that we would divert
our industrial and military strength to
the Pacific area or even to our own
continental defense the plan
has failed in its purpose
we have not been stunned we have not
been terrified or confused this very
reassembling of the 77th Congress today
is proof of that
for the mood up quiet grim resolution
which care prevails bodes ill for those
who conspired and collaborated to murder
World Peace and that mood is stronger
than any mere desire for revenge it
expresses the will of the American
people to make very certain that the
world will never so suffer again
admittedly we have been faced with hard
choices it was better for example not to
be able to relieve the heroic and
historic defenders of Wake Island it was
bitter for us not to be able to land a
million men in a thousand ships in the
Filipino but this adds only to our
determination to see to it that the
stars and stripes will fly again
overweight and Guam
yes see to it but the brave people of
the Philippines will be rid of Japanese
imperialism and we live in freedom and
security and independence
powerful and offensive actions must of
will be taken in proper time the
consolidation of the United Nations
total war effort against our economy
enemies is being a tree that was and is
the purpose of conferences which have
been held during the past two weeks in
Washington and Moscow and Chongqing that
is the primary objective of the
declaration of solidarity signed in
Washington on January 1st 1942 by 26
nations against the Axis powers
difficult choices may have to be made in
the months to come we do not spring from
such decisions
Riaan those United with us will make
those decisions with courage and
determination plans have been laid here
and in the other capitals or coordinated
and cooperative action by all the United
Nations military action and economic
action already we have established as
you know unified command of land sea and
air forces in the southwestern Pacific
Theatre of war there will be a
continuation of conferences and
consultations among military staffs so
that the plans and operations of each
will fit into the general strategy
designed to crush the enemy
we shall not fight isolated Wars
each nation going its own way these 26
nations are united not in spirit and
determination alone but in the broad
conduct of the war in all its phases for
the first time since the Japanese and
the fattest and the Nazis started along
that blood-stained course of conquest
they now face the fact that superior
parties are assembling against them go
on forever other days when the
aggressors could attack and destroy
their victims one by one destroy them
without unity of resistance we of the
United Nations will so dispose our
process that we can strike at the common
enemy wherever the greatest damage can
be done
the militarists a Berlin and Tokyo
started this war but the mast angered
forces of common humanity will finish it
destruction destruction of the milk
material and spiritual centers of
civilization this has been and still is
the purpose of Catalan is Italian and
Japanese chess man they would wreak the
power of the British Commonwealth and of
Russia and of China and of the
Netherlands and then combine all their
forces to achieve their ultimate goal
the conquest of the United States they
know that victory for us means victory
for freedom they know that victory for
us means victory for the institution of
democracy the idea of the family the
simple principles of common decency and
humanity they know that victory for us
means victory for religion and they
could not tolerate that the world is too
small to provide adequate living room
for both Hitler and God
in proof of that the matches have now
announced their plan for in crossing
their new German pagan religion all over
the world the plan by which the Holy
Bible on the cross of Mercy would be
displaced by mine camp and the swastika
and the naked sword our own objectives
are clear the objective of smashing the
militarism imposed by warlords upon
their enslaved peoples the objective of
liberating the subjugated nations the
objective of establishing and securing
freedom of speech freedom of religion
freedom from want and freedom from fear
everywhere in the world we shall not
stop short of these objectives nor shall
we be satisfied merely to gain them and
then call it a day I know that I speak
for the American people and I have good
reason to believe that I speak also for
all the other peoples who fight with us
when I say that this time we are
determined not only to win the war but
also to maintain the security of the
peace that will follow
but we know that modern methods of
warfare make it a task not only of
shooting and fighting but an even more
urgent one of looking and producing
victory requires the actual weapons of
war and the means of transporting them
to a dozen points of combat it will not
be sufficient for us and the other
united nations to produce a slightly
superior supply of munitions to that of
Germany in Japan and Italy and the
stolen industries in the countries which
they have overrun the superiority of the
United Nations in your missions and
ships must be further well so
overwhelming the Axis nations can not
off hope to catch up with it
and so in order to obtain this
overwhelming superiority the United
States must build planes and tanks and
guns and ships to the utmost limit of
our national capacity we have the
ability and capacity to produce arms not
only from own forces but also for the
Army's natives and air forces fighting
on our side and our overwhelming
superiority of armament must be adequate
to put weapons of war at the proper time
into the hands of those men in the
contact nations who stand ready to seize
the first opportunity to revolt against
that German and Japanese of process and
against against the traitors in their
own ranks known by the already infamous
name of Quisling
and I think that it is a fair prophecy
to say that as we get guns to the
Patriots in those lands they too will
fire shots heard round the world this
production of ours in the United States
must be raised far above present level
even though it will mean the dislocation
of the lives and occupations of millions
of our own people we must raise our
sights all along the production line let
no man say it cannot be done it must be
done and we have undertaken to do it I
have just sent a letter of directive to
the appropriate departments and agencies
of our government ordering that
immediate steps be taken first to
increase our production rate of our
planes so rapidly that in this year 1942
we shall produce sixty thousand planes
ten five
10,000 by the way more than the goal
that we set a year and a half ago this
includes 45,000 combat planes bombers
dive bomber pursuit planes the rate of
increase will be maintained continue so
that next year 1943 we shall produce a
hundred and twenty five thousand
airplanes including a hundred thousand
combat
second to increase our production rate
of tanks so rapidly that in this year
1942
we shall produce 45,000 tanks and to
continue that increase so that next year
1943
we shall produce 75,000 tanks third to
increase our production rate of
anti-aircraft guns so rapidly that in
this year 1942
we shall produce 20,000 of them and to
continue that increase so that next year
1943 we shall produce 55,000
anti-aircraft guns and fought to
increase our production rate of merchant
ships so rapidly that in this year 1942
we shall build eight million deadweight
tons as compared with a 1941 completed
production of 1 million 100,000 and
finally we shall continue that increase
so that next year 1943 we shall build 10
million tons of shipping these figures
and similar figures for a multitude of
other implements of war will give the
Japanese and the masses a little idea of
just what they accomplished in the
attack at Pearl Harbor
and I rather hope that all these figures
which I have given will become common
knowledge in Germany and Japan
our task is hard
our task is unprecedented and the time
is short
we must strain every existing element
producing facility to the utmost we must
convert every available plant and to the
war production that goes all the way
from the greatest plants to the spawns
from the curb automobile industry to the
village machine shop production for war
is based on men and women the human
hands and brains which collectively we
call labour our workers stand ready to
work long hours to pen out more in a
day's work to keep the wheels turning in
the fires burning 24 hours a day and
seven days a week
they realized well that on the speed and
efficiency of their work depend the
lives of their sons and their brothers
on the fighting front production for war
is based on metals and raw materials
steel copper rubber aluminum zinc ten
greater and greater quantities of them
will have to be diverted to all purposes
civilian use of them will have to be cut
further and stillbirth and in many cases
completely eliminate war costs money
so far we've hardly even begun to pay
for we've devoted only fifteen percent
of our national income to national
defense as will appear in my budget
message tomorrow a war program for the
coming fiscal year will cost 56 billion
dollars or in other words more than half
of the estimated annual national income
that means taxes and bonds and bond and
taxes it means cutting luxuries and
other non-essential in a word it means
an all-out war by individual effort and
family effort in a united country only
this all-out scale of production will
hasten the ultimate all-out victory
speed will come lost strong can always
be regained lost time never speed will
save life speed will save this nation
which is in peril speed will save our
freedom and our civilization and
slowness
well it has never been an American
characteristic as the United States goes
into its full stride we must always be
on guard on guard against misconception
which we arise some of them naturally or
which will be planted among us by our
enemies we must guard against
complacency
we must not under eight the enemy is
powerful and cunning and full and
ruthless he will stop at nothing that
gives him a chance to kill and to
destroy he is praying his people to
believe that the highest protection is
achieved by waging war for many years he
is prepared for this very conflict
planning and plotting and training
arming and fight we have already tasted
defeat we may suffer further setbacks we
must face the fact of a hard war a long
war a bloody roar a costly war we must
on the other hand guard against the feed
ISM that has been one of the chief
weapons of Hitler's propaganda machine
used time and again with deadly results
it will not be you successfully on the
American people
we must guard against divisions among
ourselves and among all the other united
nations we must be particularly vigilant
against racial discrimination in any of
its ugly forms
Tipler the prior gain to breed mistrust
and suspicion between one individual and
another one good for another one race
and another one government and another
he will try to use the same technique of
falsehood and rumor mongering with which
he divided France from Britain he is
trying to do this even now but he will
find a unity a unity of will and purpose
against him which will persevere until
the destruction of all is black designs
upon the freedom and people of the world
are in we cannot wage this war in the
defensive spirit as our power and our
resources are fully mobilized we shall
carry the attack against the enemy we
shall hit him and dip in the game
wherever and whenever we can't reach him
we must keep him far from our shores for
we intend to bring this battle to him on
his own home grounds
American armed forces must be used at
any place in all the world where it
seems advisable to engage the forces of
the enemy in some cases these operations
will be defensive in order to protect
key position in other cases these
operations will be offensive in order to
strike at the common enemy with a view
to his complete encirclement and
eventual total defeat American armed
forces will operate at many points in
the fiery American armed forces will be
on all the oceans helping to guard the
essential communications which are vital
to the United Nations American land and
air and sea forces will take stations in
the British Isles which constitute an
essential corporate in this brief world
struggle American armed forces will help
to protect this hemisphere and help also
to protect bases outside this hemisphere
which could be used for an attack on the
America if any of our enemies from
Europe or from Asia attempt long-range
rage by suicide squadrons of bombing
planes they will do so only in the hope
of terrorizing our people and disrupting
armed around our people are not afraid
of that we know that we may have to pay
a edit price or freedom we will pay this
price with a will whatever the price it
is a thousand time with no matter for
our enemies in our desperation may
attempt to do to us we will say as the
people of
have said we can take it and what's more
what's more we can get it back and we
will give it back with compound interest
when our enemies challenge our country
to stand up and fight they challenge
each and every one of them and each and
every one of us has accepted the
challenge for himself and for his nation
there are only some there were only some
400 United States Marines who in the
heroic and historic defense of Wake
Island inflicted such great losses on
the enemy some of those men were killed
in action and others are now prisoners
of war when the survivors of that great
fight are liberated and restored to
their homes they will learn that a
hundred and thirty million of their
fellow citizens have been inspired to
render their own full share of service
and sacrifice
we can well say that our men on the
fighting fronts that already proved that
Americans today are just as rugged and
just as tough as any of the heroes whose
exploits we celebrate on the 4th of July
many people ask when will this War end
there's only one answer to that it will
end just as soon as we make it end by
our combined efforts our combined
strength our combine determination to
fight through and work through until the
end the end of militarism in Germany and
Italy and Japan
most certainly we shall not settle for
less that is the spirit in which
discussions have been conducted during
the visit of the British prime minister
the Washington mr. Churchill and I
understand each other our motives and
our purposes together during the past
two weeks we have faced squarely the
major military and economic problems of
this greatest World War all in our
nation have been chaired by mr.
Churchill's visit we have been deeply
stirred by his great message to us is
welcome in our midst
now and in days to come and we unite in
wishing him a safe return to his home
or we are fighting on the same side with
the British people before alone for long
terrible months and withstood the enemy
with fortitude and tenacity and skill
we are fighting on the same side with
the Russian people who have seen the
Nazi hordes warm up to the very gates of
Moscow and who will almost superhuman
will and courage applause the invaders
back into retreat
we are fighting on the same side as the
brave people of China
those millions who before and a half
long years have withstood bombs and
starvation and equip the invaders time
and again in spite of the superior
Japanese equipment and are yes we are
fighting on the same side as the
indomitable guts
we are fighting on the same side as all
the other governments in exile from
Hitler and all his armies and all is
Gestapo have not been able to conquer
but we are the United Nations are not
making all this sacrifice of human
effort and human lives to return to the
kind of world we had after the last
World War we are fighting today for
security but problem and for peace not
only for ourselves but for all men not
only for one generation but for all
generations we are fighting to cleanse
the world of ancient evils patient ill
our enemies are guided by brutal
cynicism by unholy contempt while a
Gillman race we are inspired by a faith
that goes back through all the years to
the first chapter of the book of Genesis
God created man in his own image we on
our side are striving to be true to that
divine heritage we are fighting and our
fathers are brought up hold the doctrine
that all men are equal in the sight
above those on the other side are
striving to destroy this deeply and to
create a world in their own image a
world of tyranny and cruelty and sister
that is the conflict the day and night
now pervades our lives no compromise can
end that conflict the nether has been
the never can be successful compromise
between good and evil only only total
victory can reward the champions of
tolerance and decency and freedom and
faith